welcome to the show we are starting
again today with the phones and live
callers but don't worry if you don't
like that next week there will be no
live callers much to the pleasure of
some people and dismay of others let's
start with I think it's country code 61
I think this is a foreign call caller
from country code 61 what's your name
where are you calling from and what's on
your mind today my name is Brendan I'm
from Australia actually and it's very
early here so I just um do you really
see a point in progressives debating the
right-wing pundits because it seems like
whenever they do there's this whole
bunch of reuploads with videos titled
such and such get smashed by ben shapiro
or steven crowder or something like that
because it just doesn't seem like it's
worth that them debating them if they're
not really changing anyone mine okay so
to sort of two answers to that right so
there's kind of two questions implicit
in your question one is is it worth
debating right-wingers in order to
change their or other right wing viewers
Minds maybe not maybe not and I've been
pretty clear that I don't think it
really makes sense to really debate with
committed trumpets at this point if
you're still sort of like a trump
ideologue it's hard for me to imagine
what he could do or how somebody might
convince them to change their mind so at
the individual level I think it is
mostly an exercise in futility however
at the meta level we don't want to make
it seem as though there isn't any
opposition to these crazy right-wing
ideas so even though I don't know that a
good strategy for winning elections is
to try to change the minds of individual
right-wingers who hold fallacious or
wrongheaded beliefs we still need to
make it clear at the big picture that
there's much to debate and that these
are not going to be ideas that go
unchallenged
does that sort of make sense yeah I was
mainly thinking like as someone like
Steven crowd of us is like tank eager
yourself because I know tato is kolinsky
was recently asked if he would debate
them and he was like yeah not sure yeah
yeah I shared the I mean I think it's
something all of these folks myself
included would be open to doing because
it would attract attention and it would
get views but if we're talking about
changing the political discourse through
these debates I don't really know that
it's gonna happen Brendon I don't know
really appreciate the call great to hear
from our friends to the south in
Australia hope to hear from you again
very much appreciate it